M it's
God it's
God all right so they got we got a
Muslim brother here who's ready to do
the challenge here to prove Jesus is a
Muslim yep yep yep so first condition
you got to be a Muslim he said he's a
Muslim all right and uh so all I want is
just
historical uh information on the life of
Jesus right what we can know about what
he believed how he I his religion to
show that it matched up with Islam that
he believed in the god of Islam I would
like to start off with all my fellow
Muslims and I I have three solid facts
that Jesus Christ was a muslim okay so I
would like to start off with number one
he has uh common common ways of prayer
like my Prophet Muhammad he also got
down on all fours to pray that's number
exactly that's number one so he prays
the same number two definition of a
Muslim is to believe in one God Jesus
Christ believes in one God just like me
fellow Muslim number three the Holy
Quran was out before the Holy Bible if
you if you understand what I'm saying
and the Holy Quran was never changed the
Holy Bible has different versions the
Holy Quran was never changed there only
been one version for from the time of
start to now okay so that's just my
three solid facts that Jesus Christ was
a fellow Muslim that just just just just
to just to summarize so Jesus prostrated
so he prayed like a Muslim he prostrated
Point number two he believed in one God
right Muslims believe in one God that's
the definition ofin I got you and then
point number three the Quran came before
the Bible yes it was never changed
there's no different versions of the
Quran it's only one Quran all right let
me start with number three first I think
that's the quickest one so if um you
said the Quran came before the Bible of
course okay did the Quran come with
Muhammad right no the Quran was before
Muhammad no no it was after Muhammad
after Muhammad Muhammad had his um uh
how should I I would I wouldn't want to
call them fellow servants because it
would make them seem like Companions and
followers um of the Prophet that wrote
down the Quran that wrot down the Quran
the prophet Muhammad didn't know how to
uh read write talk or anything like that
I was told that the um that Allah gave
him the power to to to tell to recite it
exactly and and his followers WR like
wrote it down for him and I got you I
got you is that make sense okay so
Muhammad basically gave the oral message
and his companions wrote it down exactly
Okay so and that's all from the power of
Allah got you so was the Bible in
existence before Muhammad was reciting
the Quran from my from my understanding
the Bible was not um all right so here's
my question the Quran says that it came
confirming the scriptures that came
before what were those scriptures those
scriptures
before uh this is the Torah and the
gospel right I would I would have to say
I would I'm not that I'm trying to think
right now honestly my I'm getting all
this from my Iman and my uncle so just
have to think back like all right it's
all good so like cuz this you know I'm
not I'm not it's not an argument that
you can teach me so the Quran talks
about how it came to confirm the
scriptures that came before right the
scripture came to Moses and Jesus so
Moses got the Torah Jesus got the gospel
all right so the Bible basically is it's
those combined so the Bible has the
Torah in it and it has the gospel in it
as well as the other writings of the
prophets the Psalms by David and stuff
like that and there is some some um some
scripts in the in the the Quran that is
kind of like the Bible but different
kind of different yeah there's some
similarities that it draws to right and
which is which is why Muhammad the Quran
says if Muhammad isn't is doubting the
Revelation that came to him that he
should go ask the people who've been
reading the scripture before him so
because it's all in alignment so
basically if he's doubting the Quran if
he's doubting like he's a prophet or
anything like that all he has to do is
go check the scriptures and it'll it'll
you know verify what he's getting okay
so that would mean that the Bible
existed before for the Quran which would
be an Evidence the Quran is using for
itself it's saying Jews and Christians
you should believe me because I align
with what you have already so that so
you have no excuse to reject me that's
the message okay all right so that's
that's I think we could get rid of that
one but now Pro prostrating right okay
so prostrating like a Muslim yeah let me
ask you this if I said I believe in God
I think we can tackle two at the same
time if I believe in God right I believe
in one one God and I prostrate to this
God but the god that I'm saying that I
believe in is a statute that I have and
I'm prostrating to the Statue all on
fours head to the ground am I
Muslim well no because that's that
you're praying to your statue exactly so
if you're just yeah right so just
because I prostrate and just because I
believe in one God doesn't mean I'm a
Muslim exactly so in order to be a
Muslim I have to believe in Allah and
prostrate to Allah specifically right
now so that's that's good I like you man
you you got you got we can move forward
so with that being said there's Allah
has specific characteristics he has
identifiers how you know he's not a
statute how you know he's not a tree
right so he's invisible right you can't
see him he could be all around he could
be all around as omnipresent could not
be a he could be might be right exactly
so um he does he have any sons does he
have any children or she or she you're
saying Allah could be a she could be
it's an entity it's a Spirit uh energy
so Allah I would say Allah can come to
any form that that that's beautiful to
us I got any form that's beautiful to
can in any form Okay cool so it could be
a light it could be like I don't know
like how should I explain like no that
makes sense he can be whatever he wants
be a star if you yeah he can come in
whatever form he wants you're saying
Okay cool so he can come in whatever
form does he so does he have children
though does Allah I have children yeah
is he a father to you guys I would I
would I would say that I would want to
say you would want to say that okay so
if you want to say that you'll be coming
from the Bible the Bible says God is our
father but the Quran says no so the
Quran says in chapter 19 it says that
the only relationship that you can have
with Allah is a slave to master
relationship you can only be a servant
you can't be a son it says that that the
heavens and the Earth if you attribute
to Allah a son that it ruptures the
mountains crumble at the utterance at
the thought that Allah has a son so you
can't come to him as a son you can only
come to him as a servant okay if anybody
says they're a son of Allah you're
committing Sherk blasphemy and you know
he's going to curse you that's what
thean says Okay so the servant is just
like you would it's it's I would say
it's obligations that we have to to
serve to for Allah yep obeying him you
know performing the you know the prayers
and stuff Five Pillars exactly so so now
we know what we're talking about Allah
is not a father to anyone he has no
children right he's invisible he can be
whatever he wants come in whatever form
he wants but he's not a father at all
okay so you brought up prostration so in
the Bible when Jesus prostrated he said
father you know uh if it be possible let
this cup pass from me but not my will
let your will be done but the God who
he's praying to and prostrating to is
his father Allah says he's not a father
he's not the father of Jesus he can
never be a father he's but Jesus says
God is his father and that he's his son
so then that would mean that Jesus is
not a Muslim or not talking about Allah
at least right so that would mean that
he's not a Muslim so yeah some a
different God exact exactly he's talking
about a different God so that's why I
say he's not a Muslim make sense yeah so
with that being said though this is a
problem for Islam cuz it doesn't just
stop there you believe Jesus right yeah
you believe he told the truth about
himself mhm so if Jesus is saying he
just a different Prophet right he's just
a different Prophet but if Jesus is
saying he's the son of God but Muhammad
says no Jesus is not the Son of God who
do you go with I'm going to go with my
Prophet why my Prophet tell me why I
really wouldn't be able to tell you why
I just grew up Muslim I got you I don't
know any other way to go I got you it
feels like it makes more sense to me but
that's a lot of things yeah a lot of
things that we don't believe in
things like uh do you believe in bad
luck no I yeah I don't either you get
what I'm saying but a lot of people do
yeah things like that like little little
things of little things that we go on
the way of life makes more sense to me
but but notice how it in by your
intuition it made sense to you it does
make sense a lot of things make sense
like you see how we like the way we talk
it could go easily go into an argument
but it's not cuz each one teaches one
yeah exactly abely I learned a lot from
from just listening two ears one mouth
that's good so what I was going to
accomplish you on was your intuition by
your by his intuition he said yeah I
would say that God is our father right
by your by your natural thinking right
and so you're lining up with Jes more
with Jesus than you do with Muhammad
that's what I'm saying you're saying
what makes sense to you I'm saying that
what makes sense to you is what Jesus
taught yeah Jesus taught God is our
father Muhammad says no God is not our
father you naturally line with Jesus
more than you do Muhammad you know what
I'm saying so but here's another thing
how you can like cuz you can know what
the fact is the Quran says that it came
that what came before it is true all
right the scriptures the Torah the Bible
the gospel it's true you have to believe
in it we got to judge by it right this
is how we can judge the Quran right so
with this being
said if the Bible is true since it's
true Jesus says I'm the Son of God I
died for the sins of mankind and that
salvation is in me if the Quran
contradicts that then the Quran can't be
true because the bi it says the Bible is
true get what I'm saying if the Bible's
true the Quran is false it can't be both
yeah so that's that's what I'm
presenting to you today what do you
think of does that make sense what I
just said yeah everything makes sense so
I want you I want you to think of this I
say I learned a lot more for do you have
do you have things that my IM probably
wouldn't tell me do you have do you have
a Bible exactly they won't tell you this
what they're going to tell you is if you
ask them about this they're going to say
the Bible's been changed
the Bible's corrupted we we we don't
have we don't have the original I I
don't want to do I don't want to get in
trouble man I we're good it's okay um
you know um the the Bible's been changed
they'll be going against what the Quran
says they'll tell you the Bible's been
changed when the Quran says nobody can
change the words of Allah that be like a
hypocritical exactly exactly and so
unfortunately our Muslim friends who
grow up with their imams and grow up in
the culture they're not being told the
truth and there's a lot of it that is
hidden which is the truth about Jesus
without Jesus bro there is no salvation
man you got to believe and what Jesus
did for us without it we're we're left
alone and we got to face God's Wrath so
this is why I'm saying this me for me
I'm a logical thinker I believe and you
believe this too that the messages of
the prophets is consistent right yes the
prophets will all be consistent in their
message right so what we see here in the
Torah for example we see Moses taught
that the seed of the woman the Virgin
birth right her son is going to crush
the Serpent's head but at the same time
he's going to be bruised that's what he
said the Messiah is going to be bruised
how we don't know yet then we go further
further we go to Daniel Daniel says
Daniel says that around the 70 around
around the uh yeah yeah in the first
century Daniel says this about the
Messiah that he's going to be cut off
the messiah's going to come but he's
going going to be cut off he's going to
do away with sin but he's going to be
cut off he's going to be killed so
there's two we got Moses saying that the
Messiah is going to be bruised Daniel is
saying that the Messiah is going to be
killed for the sins then we jump to
Isaiah prophet Isaiah he says but he was
pierced for our transgressions he was
bruised for our sins and the lord has
laid on him the sins of usau and his
soul is an offering for our guilt so we
have Isaiah saying the Messiah dies for
us Moses says the Messiah dies for us
Daniel says the Messiah dies for us and
then Jesus comes and says what they said
was about me I came to fulfill what the
prophets already
said so we see here Moses Daniel David
and the Psalms uh Zachariah Isaiah and
in Jesus all saying the same thing that
salvation is in the Messiah but then
Muhammad comes later and says no
Jesus is not your the your lord he did
not die for your sins and he's not the
Son of God so who do we go with are the
prophets who are saying the same thing
or do we go with Muhammad who
contradicts them who do we go with if
you're if you're if you're using your
brain I would it's all on like who you
would like who you would who you believe
in like what do you believe in we
believe in all the prophets you believe
in all the prophets too right yeah but
I'm believe I'm going with muhamad so
would you go with the prophet that
contradicts the rest that's if that's if
that's my choice then it is your chice
you do have a choice yes if that's my
choice I wouldn't say that he's
contradicting the rest but he is this
everything else is like all right it's I
say it's a different way of of going
about it all right so Jesus like all
these different prophets have different
have different ways on telling you what
to do on how to do it on getting into
heaven and and things like that they
really do no listen this what I'm saying
all the prophets said to get to heaven
you got to go through the Messiah
all of them said that Jesus said it he
said I'm the way I'm the truth I'm the
life no one goes to the father except
through me he's the only way about so
what's what about when the um when
Muhammad said uh to complete the Five
Pillars you'll be able to go through go
to heaven see and that and that's that's
a different message from the prophets
Muhammad is teaching that you can if you
do this this and this this and this you
may be able to get Paradise it's not
even guaranteed but Allah might give you
mercy and you can get Paradise right
that's a different message than the what
the prophet's T exactly what I'm saying
like that's why that's what I just said
earlier when I said the the prophets
have different ways of going about
things but what I'm saying is that the
prophets they had the same way but
Muhammad is the only one who had a
different one they all said Messiah is
the way to God Muhammad says do this
this and this and this and you might get
to God so you might say that that
Muhammad's ways are Mar might be a
little strict or what are are different
are just different in general I wouldn't
say I wouldn't say strict I would just
say it goes against what God Said from
His prophets I wouldn't say it goes
against it because what what Muhammad is
telling you to do isn't it's not like
it's not committing sins you get what
I'm saying committing sins is is going
against what God no he does he does tell
you he Muhammad gives you a an outlet to
commit adultery he says like for example
this is chapter 4: 24 right adultery is
when you have sex with someone who's not
your wife right you have sex or sex with
a married person that's that's adultery
God says in the Torah and in the gospel
I'll tell you what Moses says in God
says in the Torah he says Thou shalt not
commit adultery you don't even look at
another man's wife do not covet her
don't want her right Jesus says this in
the gospel he says even if you look at a
woman and lust after her like undress
her with your eyes then you've committed
adultery with her in your heart that's
what Jesus says all right one as a
Muslim I don't I don't point out other
other sins so I wouldn't even say
anything about it I turn my head
so you can't really say that um that
he's like he's telling you to commit
sins because a lot of things that
certain I wouldn't say like I don't want
to point them out but a lot of things
that certain Christians do is a sin like
it's 2024 now and Christians are
pointing you to say that it's okay to be
a hom a homophobe notay they're not
Christians but but but some of them are
telling you that they that they believe
in Jesus Christ they believe in God and
and they will be they have whole rallies
stand right now the same thing my God
never told me I can I can kiss a man
yeah and my it might be bad that I I
kissed someone else female but at least
she was a female you what I'm saying
here here's what I'm saying if you're if
there's people that's saying that
they're Christians by name but they're
going against what Jesus taught and what
the Bible teaches they're not Christian
you know what I'm saying they're not
Christian they can claim it all they
want they're not Christian so you're
pushing you would push them away
basically no I'm calling them out just
like just like Jesus said Jesus did the
same thing he called out the false the
false leaders and the false religious
people he called them out and called
them to the truth the most loving thing
we can do is call people to the truth
even if it hurts them right even if it
hurts their feelings and goes against
what they believe we got to call them to
the truth regardless of how they feel
and so what I'm saying is is that you
have Jesus and Mo and Moses who taught
against adultery but Muhammad said that
if you you know married women are
forbidden for you you can't have sex
with married women except those whom you
capture in war if you capture a married
woman in war she's still married her
husband is alive you can sleep with her
still because she now belongs to you so
he gives you an excuse to commit
adultery to commit sin so that is wait
but as you're saying this you don't
think that was a DI like what year was
that good question what year was that
but here's the point watch I'm not going
to capture anyone in war right now and
and and keep but but but notice this cuz
there's there's battles that happen
right it's different AG time lot of
things have changed yeah but Moses is
before Muhammad right Moses is way
before Muhammad in Deuteronomy in the
law of Moses the law of the Torah it
talks about how to deal with captive
women and it says if you see a captive
woman that you find beautiful right give
her time to mour take her captive
clothes off of her and if you want to
marry her marry her and then you're able
to go into her and have sex and if you
guys aren't happy let her go wherever
she wants you are not to treat her like
a slave nor are to sell her but let her
go wherever she wants so the Bible
teaches you how to deal with a captive
woman if you go into war with another
Nation but later on is that woman not
captive she's a captive woman but you're
to marry her if you want if you want her
but if in order for me to marry her she
would have to have been captive you know
no not not necessarily you can go it no
what I'm saying is in the in the in the
context of War if you're talking about
in the context of war and then you
capture them that's what I'm saying so
as a captive woman how to deal with a
captive you have to marry her if you
want her you can't just have sex with
her you can't commit adultery I have two
women right here that still looks like
that seems like it's captive like it's
not it's still not something that the
woman chose either way it go we have to
have captive them first to be married as
a choice but look you captured her you
she was captured before that and now
she's living in in your nation now mhm
yeah so she's living in your nation
that's that's not really like I feel
like that probably wasn't it a choice
but like that's something that you
pushed her into doing so if it if it all
sounds better to you if the way you word
it you wor it to make it sound better
then it sounds better if that's the case
why does the Bible say then if they're
not H if you're not happy with you let
her go wherever she wants like I like
like you just said if it makes it sound
better it makes it sound better that's
what it says it says it it sounds a
little bit better but in the beginning
it's it's kind of the same still you
it's the same because you're still
captured so in the Quran tell me if it's
the same in the Quran it says I'm going
off what you just tell okay so I got to
go somewh to take a picture of you real
quick we'll see you bro all right love
you chlo so tell me if this is the same
you have a captive woman you see you
have to marry her in order to have her
you can't have her unless you marry her
versus another one hold on versus the
other one where do I already have her in
my possession as no she no this what I'm
saying bro like it's like I confused
with the captive part that's what I'm
saying so what's confusing all right so
captive as in like if you go look if you
go to war you go to war with a nation
you win the war so now everybody there
they're your captives men and men and
women kidnap them basically no no not
it's not you're in war it's not
kidnapped you're in war okay you're in
war so you have captives now so and now
you have captives you see a beautiful
woman God says if you want her you have
to marry her and treat her right the
Quran says she's a captive you can do
whatever you want you can sleep with her
even if she's married which one do
sounds like God to
you they're both to me there sounds the
both the same thing like they're both
they they're both wrong basically what
I'm saying both of those scenarios are
wrong okay so I'm not saying that either
one is right that's basically what I'm
trying to say if you if you understand
what if you understand what I'm saying
both to me both of those scenarios sound
wrong to me okay so this so this is
where we I wouldn't agree with neither
one of my prophets if you if you
understand what I'm saying so then you
have you must you should leave Islam
yeah I wouldn't agree with that then you
should leave Islam cuz that's what it
teaches I wouldn't say that I should
leave slam that just because I don't
agree with that one thing that you just
said but did you know that your says
that you can't be in any resistance to
what Muhammad says and be a real
believer this is
4:65 it says You by but no you will not
truly believe you're not a True Believer
unless you make Muhammad your judge and
submit to his decisions with full
submission and find no resistance in
yourself so you can't disagree with
nothing Muhammad has said so if he says
yeah you can go if you got a captive
woman you can have sex with her even if
she's married and you disagree with that
you're not a real believer my choice to
have the captive woman
right I don't have to choose to take a
woman captive doesn't mean I that that
doesn't mean that I don't think you know
how War Works have I do know how the
world works I have Choice War what do
you mean the world is at War right now
2024 there's no one getting captive and
you do you there's prisoners of War
that's what it's called no I'm just
saying like the way you were making it
scene as Captain like cap like that's
like kidnapping a woman and just taking
her they're they're not in bonds they're
not in they're not in bondage they're
allowed to live amongst you but under
your under your nation now yeah I
understand I understand that yeah so
they're not in bondage they're not
slaves you know so you so you just
taking them to your they're in your
nation now okay okay they're in your
nation now and so they have the freedom
to marry you or not okay okay so that's
what I'm saying but in but in Islam it's
not not the same it's not the same
that's your captive and that's they call
it your right-and possession means you
have rights to that to your property now
that's your possession so that's the
difference what I'm showing you yeah you
get what I'm saying fully understand so
that's what I'm showing the prophets
different saying
is I feel like that's my choice though
if you understand what I'm saying if I
was put in that position right now in
war if I would want to take a woman C
yes you're right I would have the choice
to take a woman captive if my heart
doesn't desire to take that woman
captive I would not take that woman
captive I hear what you're saying so
here's the this is what I'm talking
about I'm not talking about your choice
I'm talking about what did Muhammad
teach so what I'm what I'm saying is but
every Muslim like me has the choice to
go with exactly so but but here what I'm
saying if you go against what Muhammad
said you're not a true believer that
doesn't that doesn't mean that doesn't
mean that at all 465 of the Quran it
doesn't mean that at all you are not a
Believer until you make Muhammad your
judge and have no resistance against his
decisions you can't resist anything so
you want to for me to be a believer in
Muhammad you're trying to tell me I to
take a woman captive and make her my
slave I'm saying that you can't say that
that's wrong
you can't disagree with that but I don't
have to do it no you don't have to do it
but you can't disagree with it but I
don't have to do it correct so if I'm
not doing it thenly agree do you
disagree with it am I fully agreeing
with it though no that's what I'm asking
but am I fully agreeing with it or am I
am I even fully disagreeing with it
that's that's what I'm just not doing it
I'm just not doing it this is the
question do you agree that that's okay
do you think that's okay or do you think
it's wrong it's okay for you to do it if
you want to if you feel like that's okay
then you can do that me personally
choice
for you to do that I'm not the one to
even Point your sins out earlier you
said that that was wrong to do no for
you if you want to do that that's you
I'm not saying that yeah for if I want
to do it it would be wrong no no is it
wrong period yeah okay so that's what
I'm saying if you when you say that
that's wrong then you're disagreeing
with Muhammad yeah I could so look let
me say this right if I say that it's
wrong cool I get that I say it's wrong
but it's not me to tell you what is
right and what's wrong no but you do
know you have a you have a moral I don't
point I don't point but I'm not pointing
out your flaws or anything like that you
know what I'm saying I don't point out
your but if you love me you should if
you love me you would say hey man you
need to you need to step away from this
type of action that's wrong if I loved
you I would and and I saw you getting
ready to put your hand over a fire I
would pull your hand away from that fire
and be like hey yo what are you doing
cuz I love you I don't want you to burn
yourself you know what I'm saying so if
because I love you I won't allow you or
I'll at least let you know hey man the
direction you're going is wrong it leads
to Hellfire it goes against God you know
what I'm saying that's what love is and
because I love you I'm telling you that
Jesus says he's the only way to
Salvation not Muhammad and if you
continue with Muhammad you don't have
salvation that's what Jesus himself
teaches you know what I'm saying so
consider this man think about it do you
have a Bible yeah I do have a home you
have a Bible I have a Bible and the
Quran perfect okay so what I want you to
do read the book ofn
start there if you want just read the
book of John okay and it tells you about
Jesus it tells you who he is what he
claims about himself what he says and
you'll fall more in love with them the
more you read about him I promise you
I'm not going to I never said I hated
him no no no but what I'm saying is at
this moment you don't know him and if
you knew him you would never even give a
second thought about Muhammad or anybody
else it'll be all Jesus I promise you
take care of yourself man appreciate
come here man I appreciate the
conversation hey guys let's give it up
for our friend here man appreciate it oh
my God logic
[Music]